Now, you have quite a few cells in your body,
several trillion to be exact. And all cells in your
body had to divide at some point in their lives,
because cell division is part of the cell replication process,
where one cell will actually end up dividing into two
daughter cells. And so, for us to understand how the
DNA gets passed down to these daughter cells, we need
to understand a bit more about this whole process, in general.
Now, we've learned already that every cell has
46 chromosomes, arranged in 23 pairs. Each chromosome
exists in a pair. And half that pair came from mom, and half that pair came from
dad. Let's say I'm heterozygous for the trait
of lactose metabolism. What this means is, I
have one chromosome with a dominant allele for
lactase persistence and I have another chromosome with a
recessive allele for lactase non persistence. So these
means that this cell and every other cell in
my body is heterozygous. This means that every
cell has one copy of the dominant allele for
lactase persistence that has the ability to continue
lactase expression into adulthood. If we assume that there
is not any DNA duplication before cell division, how
many chromosomes would each of these daughter cells receive?
And assume an even or equal division in this process, even though there's no
DNA duplication. Go ahead and put the number you think, in this box here.